hallo war dies wieder einmal wanne und
heute in der pinken version ich sehe aus
bisschen wie ein cartoon charakter
ich habe das auch schon auf instagram
gepostet mir gefällt es
ich muss mich nur selber noch dran
gewöhnen vorweg ein paar sachen das
letzte video ist schlecht angekommen hat
sich dachte weil viele glaube ich auch
einfach nicht verstehen warum ich dieses
video gepostet habe aber es ist in
ordnung ich habe die beleidigung
eingesteckt ja ihn schmerze laut ja es
war nervig es ist in ordnung aber wenn
mich schon länger auf youtube kennt weiß
dass ich halt solche treue videos oder
so komische videos schon so oft
hochgeladen habe das für mich und für
die meisten auch dann nichts besonderes
ist aber die anderen naturen aber egal
und jetzt für alle die schreiben wollen
wir bekommen wieder respekt war bis mal
wieder der küche hügel ich werde bald
wieder kochen keine sorge es wird alles
wieder seinen um einen gang nehmen ich
hatte nur ein paar tage pause und es war
super doch bevor jetzt alles seinen
weiteren normalen gang gehen wollte ich
ein video machen was mir schon länger
auf dem herzen liegt und zwar dass hier
ich möchte über ein thema sprechen was
mich die letzten eineinhalb jahre sehr
beschäftigt hat was ich mit euch geteilt
habe weil ich den kanal nicht so als ja
ich sag mal so ernste themen kanal sehe
also keinen kanal der jetzt viel
probleme von mir entspricht aber da ist
jetzt ein thema ist womit ich jetzt
schon länger zu tun habe und ich glaube
sogar vielleicht deutschen helfen kann
indem ich es erzähle wollte ich jetzt
unbedingt euch die story zu erzählen
bubo bubo der titel schon ziemlich krass
ich habe ein jahr angekotzt und es ist
nicht mal klick bett und es ist nicht
mal das ist noch untertrieben
ja weil es fast alle naja ok merkt
wahrscheinlich dass es fällt mir schon
ein bisschen schwer
ich muss sagen wenn ich manchmal story
times von anderen youtube ansehen und
sie anfangen schwer zu atmen oder so
dann hätten wir auch nicht mal so ich
glaube du übertreibst ein bisschen oder
es ist wirklich es ist schluss macht
schon was mit einem
das erzählt aber ich will das unbedingt
erzählen dass ich aber ist tief in
meinem herzen und ich möchte jetzt
endlich raus schreien weil ja wie gesagt
ich denke auch vielleicht kann ich sogar
jemanden damit helfen weil mir halt auch
durch interneteinträge geholfen wurde
ich fange an ganz hinten ganz von vorne
elf hat ungefähr vor bayern angefangen
dass ich einen komischen magen bekommen
weise dass ich viele sachen dass ich mal
aufpassen muss was ich esse das ist halt
alles immer nicht so also dass dies
immer nicht alles so leicht verdauen und
oft magenschmerzen bekommen habe und ich
bin ja schon seit ich 14 bin oder soja
14 habe ich schon migräne und
migräneanfälle bekomme ich eigentlich
meistens durch licht also wenn ich zu
viel licht ins auge komme dann kriegt
man die migräne oder halt durch
lebensmittel die typischen lebensmittel
sind rotwein schokolade
ich glaube gut mit schokolade kaffee
also alkohol alles was spaß macht
und hier habe ich auch schon relativ gut
und gerne vermieden also rotwein zum
beispiel das habe ich früher ab dazu
getrunken aber danach habe ich in meine
migräne bekommen und jetzt auch sekt
mittlerweile lasse ich eigentlich
meistens kommt er die hände davon weil
ich will nicht auf einer party nach
einer halben stunde wieder geben weil
ich den stückchen sekt getrunken habe
und ja das war das ist so eine
geschichte migräne und vor zwei jahren
fing es dann anders ich halt auch
lebensmittel nicht so also nicht so gut
war und dann hat sich aber daraus oder
ich weiß gar nicht wie es dazu gekommen
ist
ich habe irgendwann angefangen wenn ich
gegessen habe oder was getrunken hat
oder beim sport war und gar nichts
gegessen habe magenschmerzen zu kriegen
mir wurde leicht schlecht aber er also
die man schmerz man da aber ich habe
durch diese magenschmerzen oder durch
die lebensmittel die ich gegessen habe
habe ich rückenschmerzen bekommen ganz
schlimm immer auf der rechten seite bis
hoch in den nacken und hier rein und das
ging dann einmal je nach vorne sodass
war so der komplette schmerz und hier im
auge als auch wehgetan und ich habe auch
dann immer schlecht anfangen zu sehen
also
wie soll man sich das vorstellen also
als ob irgendwie die als ob eine kamera
nicht fokussieren kann so fühlt sich das
ungefähr den augen nicht so richtig
fokussieren kann du siehst zwar ganz
normal und kannst halt auch sich bewegen
und so aber es ist immer irgendwie
unangenehm und du schaust immer so ein
bisschen ja weiß ich nicht ist hat sich
unangenehm angefühlt
und dann war das so dass ich das halt
von lebensmitteln bekommen und für am
anfang hat sich immer für mich angefühlt
wie die migräne besonders hier diese
einseitigen kopfschmerzen so dieser
nacken schmerzt er war wirklich ich bin
okay das kommt noch
es hat sich für mich eine migräne
angefühlt und ich muss dazu sagen wenn
ich eine migräne habe hilft es bei mir
nur ganz persönlich hilft es am besten
wenn ich eine wenn ich krieg das mit
dieser aura bin ich so ein fleck im
gesicht in der marienkirche
kriegsbegriff
dann muss ich mich übergeben gehen also
ich muss dann das was in meinem magen
das rausholen eine kopfschmerztablette
einwerfen und mich für zwei stunden
hinlegen und dann habe ich eigentlich
immer die migräne gut bewältigt wenn ich
das nicht mache manchmal versuche
einfach nur eine kopfschmerztablette
nehmen und mich hin zu legen dann muss
ich nach drei stunden mich also dann
dann muss ich das nicht mehr hervorrufen
sondern dann übergibt ich meinen körper
so dann renne ich auf kloten muss mich
übergeben aber da muss ich mich
stundenlang übergeben weil das halt ich
weiß jetzt macht es schlimmer ich habe
für mich herausgefunden dass man nicht
nicht übergebe denkt und so alles gut
und dieser kopfschmerz wahrheit wie eine
migräneattacke so es hat sich so
angefühlt ich habe zwar keine opfer
gehabt so was wahrheit ich etwas
gegessen und irgendwann fing ich halt an
den hier zu machen und es tat alles weh
also was habe ich gemacht ich hab mich
übergeben weil nachdem ich mich dann
auch übergeben habe ging das dann dann
ging der nacken schmerzt plötzlich weg
sodass hier im auge ging weg und das
habe ich so einen monat gemacht bis ich
irgendwann gemerkt habe das ist nicht
normal war deshalb das kommt zu oft vor
also am anfang war das heißt alle zwei
tage und als ich dann so zurückgedacht
habe ich habe mich diese woche schon
fünf mal übergeben firma
ist halt nicht gut das ist halt nicht
gesund das solltest du nicht tun und
dann bin ich zum arzt erst mal zu einem
arzt in meinem alten bezirk in berlin
ruhig da gewohnt habe ja und dieser
arztbesuch hat glaube ich am meisten
kaputt gemacht fürs erste weil dieser
arzt ein ich sag mal so uhren söhne war
also ein richtiger richtiges arschloch
wenn ich jetzt so nachdenke
es war nämlich hochsommer und ich sag's
dann da kurz bekleidet so bin zudem dann
rein
habt ihr meine symptome gesagt also dass
sich der kopfschmerzen kriege und mich
dann übergeben muss und das schon zu oft
vorkommt und dann guckt mich an sie
haben essstörungen und ich sage so nee
das ist halt auch nicht also das kommt
auch immer plötzlich dann habe ich an
dem tag wo es nicht gekommen ist aber am
nächsten tag war so und zwar auch egal
was ich gegessen habe ich habe
angefangen fertige nüssel zu essen weil
ich gemerkt habe wenn ich immer zu viel
ausspucken dass ich halt nicht genug
kalorien bekommen habe ich ganz
vergessen damit ich schön schön das fett
an gesammelt wird oder ich halt nicht zu
sehr ab nehme weil ich wusste eigentlich
in meinem herzen das war keine
essstörung das war irgendwas ich habe
halt rückenschmerzen und kopfschmerzen
bekommen dass wahrheit nicht normal
und er hat ballack näher der es
störungen dann sage ich sage ja dann der
mache jetzt einen bluttest und dann
werde ich ihnen zeigen dass sie mehr
stimmen haben weil alles in ordnung ist
und ich hab dann am wartezimmer gesessen
und musste fast anfangen zu weinen weil
also es war halt alle für alle die schon
mal irgendwas hatten und dann endlich
zum arzt gegangen sind
es ist so ein gefühl von endlich endlich
geht man zu jemandem und erzählt ihm
alles und möchte so quasi die hilfe
annehmen die ja eigentlich angeboten
wird und dann sitzt da jemand und sagt
mir du hast
essstörungen hierzu abgeben eine
psychiatrische anstalt oder so und dann
bin ich halt gegangen ohne den bluttest
zu machen
und ja und die nächsten tage es ist
immer ist immer in meinem kopf durch
gerettet ich habe es störungen kam eine
essstörung ich aber ich esse doch also
ich esse ja eigentlich also nee unten
und haben mich total verrückt gemacht ja
nächste station war dann dass ich zum
[Musik]
gastronomen gegangen bin und eben auch
alles erzählt habe und er hat gesagt ja
da machen wir laktose und fruktose test
ja na ja auf jeden fall hatte dann beim
arzt bei diesem puzzle test gesagt
adrian de la tour sind oder als ich sie
ja aber das also gut okay danke das
macht vielleicht die krämpfe schon mal
weg aber ich kopfschmerzen vom essen
auch wenn ich mich ist scheissegal was
ich manchmal kriegt einfach
kopfschmerzen wenn ich nur an branchen
sagt oder so betrunken habe oder stimmt
brot gegessen habe und er gesagt nee
also ist alles in ordnung so brauchen
sie nicht und dann vergingen wieder die
zeit klar ein paar wochen damit nicht
angefangen
wir wollen dann habe ich angefangen zur
osteopathin zu gehen dann hat die
osteopathin angefangen wagen herum zu
schieben und so und das hat sich schon
ein bisschen besser angefühlt aber die
kopf mehr also weiß nicht ich habe es
mir schon eingebildet dass mir besser
gegen aber an sich hatte ich halt
immernoch diesem tun
sodann habe ich wieder richtig internet
mich durch gefühlt und habe gedacht oh
chiropraktiker dem ist das aber ich
verstehe osteopathen muss man selber
zahlen und chiropraktik auch damit ich
zum chiropraktiker der hand der
chiropraktiker hat mir dann so ein
bisschen an der wirbelsäule und gefunden
hat mir so ein bisschen was nun geknackt
einmal sogar meinen nacken geknackt um
mein gott das war wohl jojoy nacken
knacksen ich war den ganzen tag
aufgenommen und so und dann war ich halt
fünf mal beim chiropraktiker und dachte
ja mein rücken fühlt sich besser an
aber es war trotzdem so dass wenn ich
manchmal gegessen habe mein rücken
wieder weh getan hat oder dieses halb
plötzlich ich habe keine rückenschmerzen
meinem rücken geht es gut ich habe einen
gesunden starken rücken
ich bewege mich genug dass wahrheit
immer dieses
und der nacken hat sich angefühlt als ob
da weil sie nicht mehr nahe reingesteckt
wird
und ja dann habe ich gemerkt okay mein
mann der die osteopathin konnte nichts
tun der chiropraktiker nicht ja dann
habe ich wohl eine psychische störung so
nach weil sie nicht nach einem jahr
also habe ich mir einen termin bei der
therapeut bei einer therapeutin gemacht
und bin dann da einmal die woche hin und
hab gesagt dass irgendwas nicht stimmt
weil ich muss mich ständig übergeben
und er hat sie gesagt ja das ist nicht
gut ja natürlich auch über viele andere
sachen gesprochen ich meine in meinem
beruf ist deshalb würde ich auch jedem
youtube hat da draußen ich bin fehlen
kittmann zur therapie ich meine in
amerika so schon länger einfach
salonfähig dass man zur therapie geht es
hilft einem wirklich viele sachen zu
verarbeiten sachen aufzuarbeiten wo man
dachte auch das dachte ich das gar nicht
so schlimm gewesen dann merkst du so
beim gespräch auch irgendwie beschäftigt
mich das doch und ich glaube dadurch
dass jetzt auch zur therapie gegangen
wenn er sich später viel davon haben
werde dass ich nichts aufgestaut ist
irgendwie raus lassen
so aber die therapeutin hat auch
irgendwann sagt man es geht ihr gut so
aber es ist trotzdem nicht gut dass du
dich halt ständig übergeben muss und ich
glaub ich weiß aber ich weiß nicht was
ich tun soll wenn sie sagt dann geh
bitte nochmals um gastronomen also bin
ich noch mal zum gast rück losgegangen
und dann habe ich also zum anderen und
dann habe ich eine mann und
darmspiegelung bekommen ja gleichzeitig
das war ein komisches gefühl nach einer
magen und darmspiegelungen aufzuwachen
zu wissen
es wird niemals so wie es mal war
ja auf jeden fall habe ich dann das
ergebnis oder hab danach gleich nach der
magen darm mit dem arzt geredet er hat
mir die bilder gezeigt ich habe wirklich
einen wunderschönen damen und magen also
bio die frau aber er hat gesagt nee ist
alles in ordnung er hat gesagt man sieht
an der magen hier kannte irgendwo man
sieht dass das gereiztes und ein
bisschen also ganz leichte entzündung
also man merkt dass ich mich oft
übergeben muss aber das ist also alles
in ordnung und ich saß da und habe
wirklich dann
aber was soll ich denn jetzt noch tun
ich kriege wirklich also das kommt vom
essen und wenn ich mich übergeben dann
geht es mir besser war muss doch
irgendwas dagegen tun können so es ist
also ich weiß ja also ich kann was
dagegen tun mich übergeben aber das ist
ja nicht die lösung also das kann man ja
nicht machen für seinen des lebens und
machen sie vielleicht mal ein
allergietest oder so aber mehr kann ich
jetzt auch nicht sagen ja und dann bin
ich beim arzt nach hause und dachte mir
gut dann ist das jetzt so dann werde ich
für den rest meines lebens kotzen nicht
immer weil ich ja keine essstörung habe
sondern also ich konnte den ganzen ben &
jerry's weghauen und mich danach nicht
übergeben habe ich aber am nächsten tag
einen apfel gegessen gegen die
kopfschmerzen los und ich musste mich
übergeben
und ja so so vergingen dann die letzten
eineinhalb jahre in meinem leben
es war auch immer sonst rankel mit
rausgehen und im restaurant essen und so
weil ich immer wusste us waren auch so
situation dann habe ich weiß nicht noch
kurz bei popcorn gegessen bin dann ins
kino
da habe ich dort popkomm und was habe
ich gegessen bin ins kino gegangen habe
gemerkt ich kann nicht mehr richtig
sehen und meinen nacken tut weh und
erreicht so wie soll ich denn jetzt zwei
stunden film gucken ja dann bin ich ins
kino rein erstmals badezimmer seite auch
super unangenehm weil da einfach offene
denkt sind also nun mit so halb
geschlossen los und musste mich dann
halt kurz ein bisschen übergeben ich
habe nicht immer ich habe beim übergeben
nicht immer da alles rausgehauen sondern
immer nur so hat und eilig habe so das
gefühl gehabt dass sie irgendwie
obendrauf liegt und nicht keine ahnung
irgendwie nicht kann ja und dann war ich
im kino musst du mich als kur zu
beginnen stunde kurz schmerz geht raus
und dann konnte ich mir den film
anschauen und das ist halt ich sag mal
so qualitatives leben sieht anders aus
ja
und so verging dann die zeit und ich
habe angefangen das in meinem leben so
zu akzeptieren und kein arzt kann sich
dann aber geht es gemacht und so
natürlich kam da nichts raus weil naja
so dann habe ich irgendwann mal ich weiß
nicht wann ich glaube so zwei drei
monaten vor drei monaten ungefähr 2 habe
ich noch mal gegoogelt weil es gab ja
nicht viele andere themen die mich
beschäftigt damals hab ich wieder meinen
google so kam aber wieder nix raus und
das weiß das war eine art da war ich
richtig deprimiert weil das hat wieder
angefangen ich lag im bett habe das
gegoogelt es kann wieder nichts raus
also ich konnte nicht herausfinden was
ich vielleicht haben könnte
doch immer so ganz schlimme sachen aber
das kennt ihr wenn man etwas bei google
eingibt dann ist es immer krebs oder
sonst was
ja und dann weiß ich dass ich auf dem
bett aufgestanden bin und mich so rum
gewälzt habe und dachte oh mann ich will
mich jetzt nicht übergeben ich hab keine
lust ist es halb einzeln nacht und ich
bin müde und weißt ja auch mal so
anstrengend also viele lockt viele leute
es übergeben mehr als super anspringt
von manchen nicht so ganz ich gehöre zu
den nicht so ganz aber selbst das reicht
einem schon aus ja und jetzt kommt es
und jetzt kommt das war eine große reise
und jetzt kommt das finale war ich wälze
mich so im bett herum setze mich so auf
und drehe mich so hin und her und
plötzlich muss ich aufstoßen
also wie wenn man viel gegessen hat
einmal dieses wurde dieses dieses wasser
nach dem essen kommt wo man halt
wirklich dann irgendwann so und jetzt
hat sich das essen gesetzt man ist nicht
mehr ganz so vollgefressen und alles ist
gut und ich saß da und plötzlich gegen
diese nackenschmerzen weg und ich habe
mich gefühlt wie der dümmste mensch auf
diesem planeten weil ich mich
wahrscheinlich nie er darüber geben
müssen sondern einfach immer nur
irgendwie trösten
das klingt so lächerlich aber das ist
wirklich das
was mir seitdem hilft mir hilft es
seitdem wenig gegessen habe ein bisschen
es zu provozieren dass sich rhythmus
aufstoßen muss weil mein magen das
irgendwie nicht hinkriegt das essen so
rein zu packen
das ist einfach nur cool da drin schild
und ich von natürlicher weise aus
einfach so und dann hat das gewoge luft
im bauch fast hilfe display was kann man
gegen luft im bauch tun und es war immer
nur luft im also lüfter der verdauung
ist im damen das ist die 1 also dass das
was ich mir gefunden habe es habe ich
habe keinen eintrag gefunden zu luft im
bauch also im magen und probleme
deswegen und dann habe ich aber
tabletten gefunden
die luft in der ganzen verdauung weg
machen und das sind meine lebensretter
seit die marke weg das ist meine
lebensretter seit drei monaten
ich habe seit drei monaten mich nicht
mehr wegen lebensmitteln übergeben also
wegen rückenschmerzen kopfschmerzen weil
ich ungefähr acht kautabletten davon am
tag nehme immer nach dem essen so wenn
ich lange nichts gegessen habe das hilft
mir auch sehr gut was unsere auch
kopfschmerzen
ich weiss man kriegt auch hier vorne
kopfschmerzen von so wenig trinken keine
sorge das weiß ich es ist andere
kopfschmerztabletten bei blähungen es
ist sehr angenehm die in der apotheke zu
kaufen man muss darauf achten dass man
nicht ständig mir gleiche apotheke geht
ich weiß dass es nicht also bei
blähungen und für luft im ganzen körper
ich habe keine blähungen das wäre
natürlich auch nicht schlimm für alle
leute wieder der offenlegung haben das
ist so ken hicks tabletten aber es ist
halt die luft im magen und das in
schäumend es macht halt magen schaum weg
also wirklich wenn ich das zwischen den
zähnen haben wir dann das zähneputzen
gehe dann macht die zahnpasta kein
schauen dann habe ich einfach nur
flüssigkeiten bund ist ganz witzig und
man kriegt das also kinder kriegen es
auch wenn die seife essen habe ich eine
apotheke hat er mir erzählt egal so und
das habe ich jetzt
und seit drei monaten kaum ich meine
leckeren minsk hätten
und mir geht es besser und ich muss mich
nicht mehr übergeben ich kriege keine
kopfschmerzen vom essen ich kann einfach
das haus verlassen weiß es ist alles gut
das wollte ich euch mit geben dass falls
jemand vielleicht auch darunter leidet
unter vielen kopfschmerzen so guckt mal
ob es vielleicht an der magen ist und
guck mal auf ihr vielleicht genau das
gleiche habt diesen scheiß mit der also
mit dem gröbsten aufstoßen das essen
setzt sich nicht richtig
ich weiß aber allerdings auch das ist ja
eigentlich nicht die lösung also ich
könnte jetzt natürlich für mein
lebensende diese karten schauen
ich frage da tatsächlich raus in die
welt und bitte versucht wirklich nicht
alle ideen was es sein könnte rein zu
schreiben weil sondern nur wenn ihr
exakt bis ich kann ja schon mal
ausschließen das liegt nicht an histamin
das liegt nicht an denn es liegt dann
keine lebensmittelunverträglichkeit es
ist durch die bandbreite jedes essen
könnte mir die kopfschmerzen machen weil
sich das nicht richtig setzt also es ist
keine so was aber vielleicht hat ja
jemand von euch ja draußen mal so unfall
miterlebt in der familie oder so und
könnte sagen wann es liegt vielleicht an
einer magen defizit so drohsel
polysilicium und ja das ist auch halt
einfach der grund warum ich dieses video
machen wollte
einerseits weil ich unbedingt oder mit
leiten möchte ich hab mir jetzt zwei
jahre bedingt durch gequält durch dieses
thema sei möglich ich habe echt manchmal
also ich habe in der zeit gemerkt dass
es wirklich scheißegal ist wie
erfolgreich du bist oder es ist wirklich
scheiß egal wie viel geld auf dem konto
ist wie was du alles die geleistet hast
ob du pinker haare hast ob du auf deinem
wohnzimmer wunderschön aussieht ob deine
pflanzen schöngrün sind wenn es dir
nicht gut geht wenn es deine gesundheit
nicht gut geht in dem moment wird alles
scheißegal nicht gut geht
und jeden tag in dem ich mich gut fühle
und sage dass ich gesund bin nichts ab
was also ist für mich ein gewonnener tag
es für mich ein tag an dem ich einfach
nur sagen danke schön weil es geht halt
auch echt anders und es geht auch sehr
sehr viel schlechter und es gibt viele
leute da draußen die mit vielen sachen
zu kämpfen haben und gleichzeitig kann
man aber immer sehen wenn ihr die
gesundheit habt ja träumt von einem
super urlaub träumen von einem schönen
auto aber wenn es euch in dem moment gut
geht und ihr gesundheitlich fit sei dann
habt ihr eigentlich schon alles
passieren leben braucht also dann habt
ihr es schon geschafft und ich hoffe
euch gibt's ein guter draußen ja und das
war aber genau der grund warum ich
dieses video hat machen wollte war
vielleicht gibt's wenn es offen eine
person ist es ist so ein plakativer satz
aber wenn es auch nur eine person ist
die dass auch hat und damit scrabble
nach dessen kopf zu kriegen denkt
irgendwie merkt das nicht was stimmt und
das jetzt ausprobiert diese tabletten
oder zu sagen ich muss auch in dem
hübschen und ihr dadurch besser geht
dann hat sich dieses video schon gelohnt
weil es ist kacke und ja das was ich
habe leider nicht geweint ich weiß es
macht s video es nicht viel besser
aber naja aber ich es kommt jetzt wieder
sammler und coole cooking videos ich
habe ganz viele am start
also ich ganz viele ideen aufgeschrieben
und das wird total weil ich mir freie
und es ist super und folgte ihr auf
instagram ist gewinnt ganz coole ist
dass dies in den nächsten wochen geben
weil ich nun mal so sagen aber bis dann
muss